what's going on guys in this video i'm
going to explain every card titan in the
history of attack on titan
i'm glad we're finally doing this
shifter because it is usually the most
underestimated of the nine titans and i
do think it deserves more recognition
as usual today i'll be breaking down the
backstory of the card titans we know as
well as explaining its abilities
and commenting on the design of ancient
card titans from the past
before we get into it one fact i wanted
to mention was that isayama originally
drew this titan
to be a middle-aged man when the card
titan was first introduced in the manga
it looked remarkably different to how it
later appeared in the anime and the
reason was that the manga version was a
man called oliver peak
sketches of oliver's face can be found
online and when you compare it to the
original card titan
it's clearly meant to be him luckily for
isayama though the human inside this
titan wasn't fully revealed until the
mali arc
so there was sufficient time for him to
just wreck on the whole thing by the
time the cart titan was shown in the
anime
pique had firmly been established as a
woman in the source material so it meant
that all of his titan never appeared on
screen
i guess he decided that a character
people could simp over was better than a
character who looked like someone's dad
but let me know in the comments which
design you think was best
moving over to the cart titan's
abilities now it is the only shifter
that walks on all fours besides the draw
titan
and its main power is its endurance this
endurance manifests itself in various
ways
with an example being how peak remains
in her titan form for months at a time
at the start of the marley arc she
needed a crutch to walk because she'd
been in her titan form for two months
when you've been that long without
walking on your two human legs it is
understandable why you would need to you
know have a readjustment period before
you can walk again
that's why peek was lying down during
the warriors meeting and it's also why
she was caught crawling on all fours
another use for the cart titan's
endurance is its ability to do
consecutive titan transformations
in this series i'd say aaron is
definitely the person who has used this
ability the most
and we've seen in the past how the
attack titan can do three consecutive
transformations
when it comes to the car titan p
confirmed that it can literally do
hundreds of consecutive transformations
which comes in useful if her titan body
is destroyed but her human body is okay
additionally the car titan could be
equipped with cargo armor and weapons
turning her into a portable machine gun
that can ram into enemies
this titan also has superior biting
strength to every other shifter except
the draw
as it has been known to bite large
chunks out of other titans
on top of that running on all fours
gives the cart titan incredible speed
enabling it to catch levi and hanji by
surprise
saving the lives of her fellow warriors
in the process anyway with that said
let's get into the backstory of peak
followed by a look into the ancient car
titans throughout history
don't forget to hit that sub button if
you haven't already and let me know if
you prefer me to do the female titan or
the colossal titan next
okay so peek is a marlian warrior from
liberio and in the present day she's had
the cartesian for around 11 years
from a young age peek was raised by her
father alone with her mother never being
mentioned once in the series so it's
kind of implied that she died but we
don't have confirmation
while she was still a child her father
was overcome with a serious illness
but as poor aliens they didn't have the
necessary healthcare to treat it
this served as peak's primary motivation
to join the malian warrior unit
as warrior families are given good
medical care most likely because they
are honorary malign citizens
over time she would eventually become
one of the seven warrior candidates who
were competing to inherit the titans and
it's clear that she was valued for her
perceptiveness
poco pointed out that it was her best
quality and throughout the series pikas
always made clever observations before
other people
when the time came for the candidates to
inherit titans pique was chosen as the
cart
and immediately assisted in the invasion
of an enemy nation
a commander noted how the car titan
allowed the army to expand their tactics
with one of those taxis being that she
would sneak bertholds into certain
locations before he detonates his
colossal titan
that tactic would be used again many
years later during the battle of
shiganshina
although that time around zeke was
helping out with peak status as a
warrior confirmed
her father was given the care he needed
but was brought to tears knowing his
only daughter
had drastically shortened her lifespan
to save him when the time came for molly
to invade paradise island
zeke and peak were chosen by the army to
stay behind in liberio
because their presence was needed to
deter enemy nations however
five years into the mission mali hadn't
heard anything from rhino and the gang
so the remaining warriors were sent to
visit the island along with a few malian
soldiers
the khan titan was used to carry many
supplies including this special gas
containing zeke spinal fluid
which as we saw it was used to turn the
people of ragako into titans
a couple months later she was used again
during the battle of shiganchina as it
was peaked that observed the survey
called soldiers the night before
and informed the warriors that the
scouts were approaching in the battle
itself she was used as a means of
transporting cargo
such as rocks or the colossal titan but
her biggest achievement
was when she single-handedly saved the
lives of both zeke and reiner
both men were thoroughly beaten by the
scouts but the cart titan speed was able
to catch them by surprise
as she stole the warriors back from
enemy hands in terms of the design of
her titan
its defining feature is its elongated
mouth which provides her with a greater
biting strength than the original cart
titan design
peak shifter is around 4 meters tall
when standing in its normal position
and when fully suited up she has armor
covering her face and the panzer unit on
her back
the fact she needs armor implies to me
that she might not have titan hardening
powers
however this is still an open question
now next up we're gonna look at the
ancient
card titans throughout history but bear
in mind that there will be
major spoilers ahead for the final arc
of attack on titan so if you're an anime
only then i would recommend you stop
watching
okay so the first ancient shifter is the
okapi card titan
which swallowed armin in the same way
that pete came in to save zeke
i didn't know what an okapi was until
this titan made an appearance
but according to google it is a relative
of the giraffe and there are less than
35 000 left in the world
as you can see this shifter is the size
of a regular cart titan but its most
distinctive feature is obviously its
animal head
throughout history the heads of card
titans have always had animalistic
features
with the very first carciton having a
mouth like a horse
the occapie just takes this concept one
step further by literally having the
head of an animal
but overall it's not that strange in
real life this creature is known to have
a long tongue which can be used for many
things including grooming its ears and
eyes
but in the attack on titan universe it
used this tongue to make out with almond
instead
moving over to the wolf cart titans
these were two shifters that could be
seen in chapter 135
and the fact they looked so similar
tells us a few things we already knew
that family members who inherit the same
titan
are likely to share some features in
common with the galliard brothers being
the best example of this
given that the cart titan was held for
hundreds of years by a noble family in
elder it stands to reason that these two
wolf titans were members of the same
family
having a wolf head might have just been
their thing i mean it is a pretty cool
animal to get
and i imagine that it would have had
stronger biting power than peak
this next shifter i originally included
in my video about all draw titans
but today i'm going to hedge my bets and
i'm going to say that it might be a cart
titan as well
or potentially a hybrid of the car titan
draw titan
and beast titan it's already been
established that when the original
founding titan died
her powers were split between her
daughters that means that at some point
during history
there were at least three hybrid titans
and this crocodile could be one of them
it has a long mouth and is a similar
size to most car titans but its body
also has animalistic features
for example it has a tail and rigid
spikes on its back which is something i
would expect to see from a beast titan
instead
on top of that it has sharp claws like
the draw titan so i'm thinking that it
might just be a combination of all three
we have no way of confirming this one
way or the other so i figured i may as
well include it in this video
be sure to let me know which was your
favorite car titan design and until the
next one
peace out